♪ ♪
>> Tammy: LET'S DISCUSS THE
REALITY OF THE DOUBLE STANDARD
IN AMERICA, THE IDEA THAT SOME
PEOPLE, IF THEY ARE THE RIGHT
PEOPLE, GET SPECIAL TREATMENT
WHILE OTHERS SUFFER POLITICALLY
DRIVEN ATTACKS AT THE HANDS OF
MEDIA AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THIS WEEK, THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TURNED ITS RATING OF
RUDY GIULIANI'S APARTMENT INTO N
PROVIDING NEW CONTENT FOR THE
LIBERAL MEDIA TO DROOL OVER.
MEANWHILE, IT HAS BEEN KEEPING
THE HUNTER BIDEN INVESTIGATION
AWFULLY QUIET.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE WE WILL BE
SEEING ANY BIG RAIDS INVOLVING
HIM IN THE COMING MONTHS.
HE IS A DEMOCRAT PRESIDENT'S SON
AFTER ALL.
JOINING ME NOW WITH REACTION IS
TOM COTTON.
HE IS A MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR.
WELCOME ABOARD.
THANKS FOR JOINING ME.
>> TAMMY, THANKS FOR HAVING ME
ON.
I APPRECIATE IT.
>> Tammy: WHAT IS FASCINATING
HERE AND AS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SEE IT IS THAT WE SEE CERTAIN
AGGRESSIVE ACTIONS REGARDING
SOME PEOPLE BUT NOT OTHERS.
I WOULD SAY THAT IS ONE REASON
WHY PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ELECTED
IN THE FIRST PLACE IN 2016 WITH
THIS SEEMINGLY SENSE OF AN
IMBALANCE BETWEEN LAW AND ORDER
AND THE RULE OF LAW AND WHO IT
APPLIES TO.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE TIMING
OF THIS RAID ON THE MAYOR
HAPPENING ON THE NIGHT OF THE
STATE OF THE UNION EFFECTIVELY,
AND OF COURSE, HUNTER BIDEN WHO
IS ACTUALLY UNDER INVESTIGATION,
WHICH A LOT OF PEOPLE MIGHT NOT
KNOW.
HE IS GOING TO BE TEACHING, OF
COURSE AT TULANE UNIVERSITY
WHILE HE IS UNDER INVESTIGATION.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF ALL OF THIS?
>> WHILE TAMMY, THERE IS A DEEP
DOUBLE STANDARD THAT PERVADES
THE LEFT IN AMERICA.
IT'S NOT JUST IN OUR GOVERNMENT.
AS YOU POINT OUT, THERE WAS A
SENSATIONAL RAID OF
MAYOR GIULIANI'S APARTMENT.
I DON'T KNOW THE STATUS OF THE
INVESTIGATION SO I CAN'T COMMENT
ON IT BUT HUNTER BIDEN IS UNDER
INVESTIGATION AND THAT
INVESTIGATION SHOULD BE PRETTY
SPRAWLING, WHETHER IT'S FLYING
INTO THE ALCOHOL TOBACCO AND
FIREARMS ON GUM APPLICATIONS OR
POTENTIALLY WORKING WITH FOREIGN
AGENTS IN UKRAINE, CHINA, AND
OTHER AGENTS AS WELL.
BUT YOU ARE RIGHT.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANY HIGH-PROFILE
RAIDS WITHIN THE BIDENS HOME OR
ANYTHING ELSE.
BUT THIS DOUBLE STANDARD
PERVADES THE LEFT.
JUST LOOK AT AMAZON.
I SENT A LETTER TODAY TO
JEFF BEZOS ASKING HIM WHY THEY
PULLED A HIGHLY ACCLAIMED
DOCUMENTARY OF CLARENCE THOMAS
DURING BLACK HISTORY MONTH ON
THEIR STREAMING SERVICE THAT
THEY WERE STILL OFFERING FOR
FREE.
DOCUMENTARIES ABOUT LEFT-WING
TERRORISTS HEAR IT OR JUST
CONSIDER WHAT HAPPENED TODAY TO
TIM SCOTT.
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES TODAY
ALLOW THE LEFT TO SMEAR
TIM SCOTT AFTER HIS SPEECH LAST
NIGHT ATTACKING HIM FOR THE
COLOR OF HIS SKIN.
THAT WENT ON FOR HOURS.
HOW LONG DO YOU THINK IT WOULD
HAVE TAKEN TWITTER TO PULL DOWN
THOSE POSTS IF IT WAS ABOUT SAY
KAMALA HARRIS OR BARACK OBAMA?
>> THIS IS WHAT CONCERNS US, OF
COURSE.
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT BIG TECH
CONTROL IN THE CONVERSATION IN
THE COUNTRY, MAKING DECISIONS
THAT ARE RACIST.
THIS IS A CURATED DECISION WHEN
IT CAME TO ALLOWING THAT TO RUN
FOR 11 HOURS.
THIS IS PART OF THE DEMOCRAT
PLAYBOOK.
ITS HAND-IN-HAND WHEN IT COMES
TO SMEAR INCOME ESPECIALLY
MINORITIES WHO DON'T CONFORM.
BUT REALLY ANYONE.
JOSH HAWLEY GETS CANCELED HIS
BOOK FROM SIMON AND SCHUSTER.
IT TELLS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
THAT YOU WILL BE PUNISHED.
BUT WE ARE SEEN, OF COURSE, I
THINK WE HAVE A GOOD HISTORY AS
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND TO NOT
PUT UP WITH US.
HOW DO YOU SAY CONGRESS QUESTION
WHAT DO THEY HAVE A ROLE?
WE KNOW THERE ARE ALWAYS
MEETINGS.
WHAT CAN WE DO TO PUSH FURTHER
ON THIS WHEN IT COMES TO
LEGISLATION OR MORE PRESSURE
FROM THE GOVERNMENT FOR THEM TO
STOP IT?
>> WHILE TAMMY COME WHEN IT
COMES TO CONGRESS' ROLE OVER THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH, WE HAVE TO
CONDUCT OVERSIGHT.
IF YOU RECALL FROM THE OBAMA
ERA, EXPOSE THE FACT THAT THE
OBAMA IRS IS TARGETING ANY GROUP
WITH THE NAME TEA PARTY AND ITS
NAME WITH ADDITIONAL AUDITING
AND HARASSMENT.
WHEN IT COMES TO SOME OF THESE
WOKE CORPORATE CEOs, CEOs OF
DELTA OR COCA-COLA, ANY TIME
THEY START WITH LEFT-WING LIES
LIKE THEY DID IT ABOUT GEORGIA'S
ENTIRELY SENSIBLE ELECTION LAW,
WE CAN'T ROLL OVER AND WE HAVE
TO DEFEND COMMON SENSE
PRINCIPLES AGAINST THESE
LEFT-WING MOBS WHETHER THEY
ORIGINATE IN SOCIAL MEDIA OR IN
THE CORPORATE WORLD.
>> Tammy: I THINK THIS IS KEY.
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE LOOKING TO
KNOW WHAT THE RHETORIC CAN BE,
THAT THEY ARE NOT ALONE IN
THINKING THIS IS AWFUL.
THAT IS THE OTHER MESSAGE.
WHEN THEY HEAR OTHER OF THEIR
FAVORITE PEOPLE PUSHING BACK.
THEY ARE NOT ALONE.
THERE IS A WAY TO SAY NO TO
THIS.
THAT WE CAN PREVAIL AS LONG AS
WE DON'T SURRENDER TO THEIR
EFFORT TO SILENCE US.
AND YOU ARE LEADI